hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
here's a mathematical problem that might
just turn your world upside down
solve for x in the equation
x plus 8 all over 6 is equal to 9
divided by the quantity 5 plus x
once you solve this problem i want you
to flip the entire equation upside down
and solve for x again
this challenge comes from peter rowlett
on twitter
pause right now to give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for a solution
[Music]
in 1908 the british magazine strand
published this interesting curiosity the
word chump reads exactly the same way
upside down
this is an example of an ambigram which
is a word art form or other symbolic
representation whose elements retain
meaning when viewed or interpreted from
a different direction perspective or
orientation
ambigrams are not just limited to words
here's an example of a mathematical
ambigum that comes from adam goucher
this equation reads the same upside down
as it does right side up and it's a true
equation
remarkable
here's my personal favorite ambigram
take the multiply by lines diagram which
many people are calling the tall walker
square
you can actually solve other problems by
viewing this diagram from different
perspectives
if you rotate the diagram each 90 degree
turn will give you a different diagram
you can even flip the diagram and get
the mirror image to solve different
mathematical problems from the same
diagram
it's an incredible geometry
so now let's return to the original
problem
we'll solve it by cross multiplying and
then we're going to expand this binomial
and simplify
we end up with a quadratic equation
we can solve this equation by factoring
and we get the two solutions x is equal
to 1 and x is equal to negative 14.
now let's return to the original problem
we now need to solve this upside down
so first let's rotate this equation
upside down
we'll solve this just as before
we'll cross multiply
then we'll expand and simplify and end
up with a quadratic equation
we end up factoring just as before and
we get the same solutions x is equal to
1 and x is equal to negative 14.
amazing
this equation is a type of mathematical
ambigram that has the same exact
solutions whether we solve it right side
up or if we solve it upside down
wow
this is a really fun quadratic equation
and it opened our eyes to the wonderful
world of ambigrams
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support